[Music]
Europe has a problem with waste and it's
piling up
not enough recycling and too many
landfills are an unsustainable scenario
but the European Parliament is backing
measures for change new plans to keep
waste out of the trash bin and make
landfills a thing of the past at the
center of the European Union's circular
economy package a policy that aims to
not only increase reusing and recycling
but also to prevent waste through better
packaging as well as improved lifestyle
and business choices internet finish
along Olivia Kerry while Douglas
testamentary silty mocking whatever
horoscope you are killed in a political
is beautiful name is ur important
occasion of revista inter alia Cousteau
pocket or Eve Arden Oh Sakura mental
image really prevention and Ella generis
and very few tea today
less than half of all municipal waste is
recycled or composted by 2035 the EU
wants to see that number rise to 65
percent while at the same time limiting
the amount of waste that reaches
landfills to ten percent with other
targets focused on producing better
materials and green incentives for
businesses the EU believes the measures
will also contribute to creating more
green jobs soon importantly position
authenticity may Altria misery
compressing más tvoaqui toma la cosas
importantes o Trini ariake puntos de una
política Kevin Ella did it soon in the
rain were a little pocket in particular
implementing these measures will be left
to EU Member States
a major challenge for some that continue
to rely too heavily on landfills but as
Europe shifts to a circular economy the
path to prosperity will soon become a
sustainable one
you